find how many four-digit numbers excuse
me can be forms using the digits 5 6 7 8
& 9 5 6 7 8 & 9
I won't we get to choose from for the
intents and purposes of what I want to
illustrate to you I'm just interested in
part a no digit is to be repeated so
when we think about the permutation for
this right if we think about our
notation we would say using this some
permutation notation would say I've got
5 things to choose from I would say 5 P
now have a look at what the question
says how many numbers digits rather do I
want to choose I want to choose four of
them right I want a four digit number so
I'd say 5 P 4 are you okay with that now
I want to cycle back to the definition
because you could just go to your
calculator you just punch that number
straight in and you would get an answer
right but I actually want to think about
this just a little bit further okay
let's think about this in terms of a
factorial definition of 5 P 4 okay if I
say this is a fraction right what's on
the numerator what factorial will be
there look it's a it's a no it's like
half a page ago right it's gonna be 5
factorial and how many things you have
to choose from but then on the
denominator what do I get what's in the
brackets it'll be yeah 5 minus 4 right 5
take away 4 factorial 5 factorial
happens to be I think 120 from memory
and then on the bottom there you've got
1 factorial a 1 factorial of course is
just 1 times those disease just 1 so
you're just going to get 120 out of that
that should be your answer okay but we
had an interesting conversation down the
front one you know you can misread a
question like this very easily to say oh
I've got 5 things to choose from I'm
just going to make a five letter word
now something really interesting comes
out that you can observe and think about
this with me if you accidentally solve
that question if you are choosing five
digits to make a five digit number you
would not say five P 4 you would say 5 P
5 okay now again if we think about what
this means in factorial notation there
are two things that I want to point out
firstly if you have a look at this down
the bottom what do you get
on the bottom that 5-5 is just going to
give you zero so you have zero factorial
on the bottom okay now what this means
is because zero factorial is just equal
to 1 how many ways are there to arrange
to permute zero objects one way here it
is there it is is this a single way
right so this thing is just equal to
five factorial which we knew from the
beginning right like see this situation
here 3 factorial that's 3 P 3 right but
then you realize wait a second if if
that is one just like this is 1 then
these two things are the same that five
P 4 and 5 P 5 in fact are equal to one
another that seems a bit
counterintuitive because it feels like
when you're choosing you know more
numbers you should have more choices ok
now I asked you guys to have a think
about this down the front because they
stumbled upon this question I don't know
if you guys came up with an answer
did you come up with an answer for it ok
we can all come up with an answer for it
because the answer is already on the
board and presumably in your books if
you kept up you're working late
why would 5 P 5 and 5 p4 be the same
thing well let's go to the scenario here
write 5 p4 you're picking out of the
digits and you're making a four-digit
number so for example you might choose
the numbers 5 6 7 & 8
okay so here is one of the choices one
of the permutations right if I now
change this situation and say now I'm
interested in five digit numbers how
many choices do I have for this last
number I've only got I've only got one
choice right so out of this particular
option right how many branches go off of
this and the answer is just just one
branch right the branch that goes to 9
which is exactly what we already
observed over here do you see this right
if you are picking the UM the nth option
there are no more choices each time
you're only getting one twice out of
each one which is why you can see from
this tree diagram that 3 P 2 which is
this part here 3 P 2 equals the same as
3 P 3 do you see it you understand
what's going on so that's why
numerically you can see this pattern
which it's they're the same it's the
same problem that you're solving
even though
sounds like it would be different okay
all right so that's the first thing one
illustrate you probably did five and we
just blew right through it but I think
about these situations before you go on
too quickly now can I ask all of you to
have a look at 19 with me most of you I
would expect they're not up to 19 yet so
I actually want to do this one together
because it's got a little more
complexity to the situation then the
previous questions have a look at 19
find how many arrangements of the
letters of the word behaving and I want
to have a look at all of these together
with you so here's part a how many
arrangements end in ing sorry it's just
energy isn't it is that right
Indian NJ okay so normally if we were
having a look at the word behaving the
first thing you do is you would count
the number of letters right because
that's the number of things you have to
choose from how many letters are there
in the word behaving there are eight
letters right so normally you would
start off by saying 8p whatever right
but because they've said in this first
part we want all the words to end in ng
right if you think about this again go
back to you know when you were doing our
boxes right if you drew eight boxes here
can you draw this with me actually here
we go I'll have it and then I'll have
again and then I have one more time
there are my eight boxes okay here the
condition means you don't have free
choice for the entire thing you can't
just start over here and say eight
choices right in fact the first thing
you should deal with is this restriction
it's like when we had conditional
probabilities remember one dealt with
that and we would say he's your doctor
Graham here's all your options but if
they provide some condition you have to
knock out some of the options and say
these are not part of the sample space
same deal here right so if I end in ng
okay there's my ending it's fixed in
place the only arrangements I'm
interested are the ones where this is
already there now when I have a look at
the beginning here how many choices do I
have for the first spot I don't have a
Denny mordioux oh yeah I only have six
I've only got B eh a V and I so I would
say six choices
and now I would say five and then four
and then three and then two and then one
okay does this make sense so this is
going to be six factorial or six p6 if
you like and that's going to be all the
options once you've taken these out of
the running this makes sense okay now
when we push on this a little further it
gets more complicated because sometimes
it's not always fixed in a particular
position Part B says I'll actually I
have to get to Part C I'll wait to that
one so Part B says begins with three
vowels begins with three vowels so I'm
gonna write that down so now when I have
a look here and I draw out my slots here
there's four there's eight okay so when
I have a look at these three up the
front I don't have like eight options to
choose from because I have to begin with
one of the three vowels so how many
choices do I have for the first of those
three vowels there are three fouls I can
choose any of them there will be three
choices for that first one right when I
choose the second letter it'll be two
I've got two veils left there's only one
vowel left at that point so 3 times 2
times 1
and now I've dealt with the vowels so
now I can move on to the rest of the
word how many choices will I have for
this spot yeah it's the five continents
right then 5 4 3 2 1 and off you go okay
so this is going to be 3 factorial
multiplied by 5 factorial and that will
give you fewer options again because
you're even more restricted okay the
last one yeah I'm gonna put it up here
the last one I think is the most
interesting because it extends this
naturally to say well what if I let the
vowels go anywhere is that what it says
three vowels occurring together but it
doesn't say where they are okay so for
Part C three vowels together just put
your pens down and watch the way I do
this one because I'm gonna do it a
little bit differently to the others
okay
for each of these situations I was
dealing with eight lettuce and I had an
eight-letter word to create so that's
why I created eight slots okay
but here I want to reconsider the
problem a little differently right if
the three vowels always have to be
together but they can be anywhere within
the words start middle and etc okay I'm
going to think of the three vowels as an
object on their own let me say that
again the three vowels right I'm not I
can't place them separately right so I'm
gonna think of them as like one whole
object which I'm gonna place in one of
the slots now if they're three vowels
all together are one object how many
different objects do I have to choose
from when I use all the letters you have
the five consonants right and then
you've got this super object a sixth
object which is all the vowels all
together does that make sense so now I'm
going to instead of you can pick out
opinion instead of doing eight boxes I'm
gonna do six okay now I've got my six
objects my five consonants and my my
super vowel object right so if I think
of them each I would say well I've got I
can pick any of those six to put in the
first spot cuz the vowels can be
anywhere they can be the start like here
right the vowels could be next as well
so I'm gonna go by 5 by 4 by 3 by 2 by 1
ok so now I placed all the content into
somewhere and the vowels together are
somewhere in that spot ok but now
suppose suppose the vowels are here
right suppose I put them in there
well this vowel object has more
complexity there's three spots that I
can put those vowels into within that
super object right so how many choices
will I have each time three then two
then one does that make sense so you can
see here I've got to multiply all these
together which will give me the six
factorial but then I've also got to
arrange the vowels between themselves
which is three factorial which would
give you more options okay
now lastly I'm going to say is what is
the connection between Part B and Part C
I mean the connection between the
answers
now answer every there was 3 factorial
times 5 factorial here my answer is 6
factorial times 3 factorial hmm so in
other words my answer here right to get
to here all I do is multiply by what's
the difference it's just 6 now why
should that be hmm well here's one
version of those right this is the
version where it's in the first spot
okay but I could also put them in the
second spot or the third or the fourth
or the fifth or the SIF in other words
it's like this situation but I have to
do this six times because it doesn't
have to be at the start it could be the
next one over well the next one over and
I could do this one two three four five
six times okay so I could get from here
to there just by saying it's the same
thing but you don't have to put at the
start you could put it in the second
spot or the third or the fourth or the
fifth or the six that's why there are
six more six as many times as options
okay so when you this two things I want
to pull out of that number one and first
deal with your restrictions okay if they
give you a condition they're like we
want to meet this first then deal with
that first and then see what is left
secondly if they give you some condition
that within itself you can rearrange
then you need to think about that on its
own has its own sub problem within the
problem that you're solving okay